President Biden getting slammed over a
split screen moment as Americans at Ohio
say they are getting sick from toxic
chemicals the president was thousands of
miles away in Poland to give a speech
about unending support for Ukraine
our support for Ukraine will not waver
NATO will not be divided and we will not
Tire Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia never
one year after the bombs began to fall
Russian tanks rolled into Ukraine
Ukraine is still independent and free
oh man but Biden's foreign trip isn't
sitting well with the mayor of East
Palestine
that was the biggest slap in the face
that tells you right now he doesn't care
about us so agree uh he can send every
agency he wants to but uh I found that
out this morning and one of the
briefings that he was in the Ukraine
giving millions of dollars away to
people over there not to us and I'm
furious
mayor Pete says he will finally visit
Ohio's toxic train site but only when
the time is right and boasts that his
experienced as mayor has prepared him
for this moment
I am planning to go and uh our folks
were on the ground from the first hours
look I was mayor of my hometown for
eight years we dealt with a lot of
disasters natural and human and one of
the things I noticed very quickly is
that there's two kinds of people who
show up when you have that kind of
disaster experience people who are there
because they have a specific job to do
and are there to get something done and
people who are there to look good and
have their picture taken when I go it
will be about action on rail safety
that's amazing and 18 days after the
crash the EPA taking charge of the
cleanup and ordering the rail Company to
pay for it the agency's chief made
another visit to the site and sipped the
water
we uh I'll tell you we believe in
science so we don't feel like we're
being a guinea pig but we don't mind
proving to you that we believe the world
okay
thank you thank you so much
services for those three gentlemen will
be held in a week
kidding I'm kidding they're fine they're
fine Piers welcome to the show thank you
great to be back it's great to have you
back what do you make of this split
screen moment I know this isn't this is
kind of an easy talking point you can
always look at something that's going on
in a foreign capacity go why is it he
doing this what do you make of this
sincerely I I think you can actually
split your view I think that I would
have a strong view that it was correct
for President Biden to go to Ukraine and
it was a bold move and it was a two
fingers up at Putin this week in the
first anniversary week and I think he
was right to do that but I think what's
been going on uh down in East Palestine
is absolutely extraordinary and mayor
Pete seems completely deluded this guy
keeps saying I'm planning to go it's
been three weeks what are you planning
you get on a flight I could only liken
it if there was a train derailment in
the UK for example the transport
secretary whose specific brief was
trained incidents did not go for 18 19
days to the scene they would be fired
they'd be gone they to be torched
because everybody would think that was
outrageous he he seems to think that the
longer he leaves it the better he looks
I've got a I've got a little wake-up
call for you man B the longer you leave
it the worse it looks buddy get your ass
down there now because he's so wrong
about what he said
actually it's really important when
public figures go to these scenes you
know I can always remember on 9 11 when
President Bush went down there very very
soon and stood there he wasn't meeting
the criteria that mayor Pete has laid
down exactly right he was just doing a
photo op but what a powerful photo op
and when he spoke to the world the world
knew the president was taking this
incredibly seriously and that's the
point I love that I love the criteria
though I we should all be doing that you
know what I would I would go get
groceries but uh I'm gonna go when we
need them I don't want to go to the
store just for some lousy symbolic
gesture it's very galling I have a few
things to say so this is the same crowd
that continues to this day to criticize
George W bush for flying over Hurricane
Katrina and even like you could say you
could make all those arguments like well
it was truly busy and you couldn't get
down there in the time and you didn't
want to take away resources but
regardless they still make fun of him
for that this is 18 days after the fact
at this point you might as well not go
and for the president of the United
States it was his instincts weren't
telling him I need to go immediately
his instincts didn't tell him I need to
go before I go to Ukraine his instincts
didn't say I need to at least tell them
I'm going to be there after my trip to
Poland so that they would know that I'm
going to be there I'm intending to go
and he never called a cabinet meeting he
never said mayor Pete get your butt over
there you never said the vice president
when you're finished in Munich can you
please head over to East Palestine we
need them to know that they have support
they never talked he didn't do any of
that and do you think about the other
things that they care about you know
when they care about something how many
events did they do after Georgia passed
their law on Jim Crow 2.0 yes everybody
the entire Capital press down here yeah
the entire path it was on high alert
that that was the most important issue
that you had to go and do the
president's instincts were wrong on this
it would have been easy for him to say
I'm going on Saturday or I'm going on
Sunday or I'm going to at least let them
know afterwards he didn't do any of that
so he is I think rightly getting the
criticism I don't think it's wrong for
him to go to Ukraine I think that's fine
great and it makes sense because he was
already going to be in Poland but that
his instincts didn't tell him and his
heart didn't tell him I should go see
these people first yeah he deserves it
what do you think Joy what do you think
about this year anniversary how do you
feel about the war going so far yeah you
know I love the Optics of President
Biden walking strolling down the streets
the sirens went off that hadn't gone off
in a few weeks we know they called
Russia to let him know he was going to
be there so those were legitimate Sirens
of course they were certainly they were
under aerial attack and uh you know he
puts his aviators on and he can't be
harmed one thing President Biden the
Democrats and even Republicans that are
associated with the swamp need to
understand is that Americans of all
walks of life they're going even more
weary of what we would call a war sold
on the stump speech and that's what that
was today that's what that was in Poland
this is not an indictment on us helping
Ukraine I don't have the information to
have an educated opinion on that but
this is a war sold to us on a stump
speech and I've just happened to fight
two of those myself and I left you know
probably the least impressive parts of
me over there with one of them but when
you move when you pivot this
conversation to Ohio where's the trust
the leadership the explanation of this
that creates an understanding that
allows us to say this community is safe
well you know maybe Buddha judge being
in DC I don't know if this train was
headed west maybe he's looking at the
root of the problem maybe maybe he's
pulling the administrative uh action or
what this Administration does he may be
looking for the root of the problem but
those people in that town don't care
they don't care about excuses is he
waiting 18 days because he's not sure if
he can breathe the air you know that's
the kind of rumor that comes from this
isn't Trump going tomorrow all right
that that you think would get them to go
I mean is that if that doesn't get you
on a plane yes Donald Trump down there
right grandstanding if that doesn't make
mayor B got on the next plane there's
something wrong with it no but you know
he's above that he won't get you know he
won't count he's only going to go for
the right reason to charge and he's
going to tell us what the right reasons
are soon I'm sure
so why does the president of the United
States visit Ukraine on President's Day
imagine that you're sitting in Palestine
Ohio imagine you're afraid to drink the
water take a bath wash your kids you're
worried about breathing the air you've
got all kinds of problems and the
president hasn't visited and FEMA has
refused Aid the Secretary of
Transportation only mentioned it after
he was embarrassed into it and mentions
it in a tweet but imagine sitting there
as the President of the United States
tells people in Ukraine we are with you
until the end
if you're sitting in Palestine Ohio
you're saying to yourself is he with
these foreigners Until the End imagine
sitting there you can't get anything but
he gives a half a billion dollars to
Ukraine and when does the money enter
Ukraine we've given them 113 billion
dollars and the UK has given them I
think it's 8 billion what's up with that
Pierce
and the Europe could resist the European
Union
well maybe they're smarter than we are
okay maybe that's what it is but hang on
you can't just raise a hand right you
hang on
right wait a minute wait a minute wait
but EU gives 40 billion at some point
we've got to say when is enough when is
the off ramp and imagine listening to a
president now that the EPA is deciding
they're coming out the EPA is like the
fox watching the hen house so our issue
is look I've given given money to
Ukraine it's not that I have a problem
with it my problem is why are we
treating American citizens like this why
do we leave American citizens in
Afghanistan why do we allow American
citizens to be overrun at the southern
border I could go on and on why do we
allow the Chinese to to hover over our
intercontinental ballistic missile sites
and now all of a sudden he's on a world
stage ranting next thing you know Putin
comes out and he says he says well now
I'm out of the nuclear treaty I mean
things are ramping up for what reason
well because the dictates are invaded a
sovereign Democratic country and he
needs to be beaten that's the reason how
many years do we stay there well until
the ukrainians get the job done because
it seems to me they're prevailing a lot
longer than anybody thought but we all
we know the ugly reality the moment we
pull the money out their dust
yeah so we're but we're stuck with this
forever so we have no choice this is
basically what we've done is we've
bought a money pit we bought a vacation
home that we're never going to see you
know what I mean and it's going to be
Rubble when it comes give up and throw
back at you that it's freedom and
democracy is what you're seeing and
they're invisible things right but they
are incredibly important but we don't
have it in this country well there are
lots of things in this country which are
wrong
that argument was for Iraq that argument
was for Afghanistan and look where both
of them are now and where we are now
yeah so yeah at least show a strategy
But ultimately I remember the first Gulf
War for example where America didn't
hesitate to go in and get rid of Saddam
Hussein and that was for the right
reasons it was an attack on freedom and
and it was defended right I remember
that was the operation right and so I
just think sometimes you have to
remember what is the fight actually
about yeah how can a Brian kill Mead I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now